[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
good day walter hello martin
let's get right into it what are we
doing today we're doing a summary of the
signs of the times so that we can take
what happened throughout this year and
the times that we are living in
and concentrate it into one little
package so that people can have easy
access to it
so let's open with the word of prayer
our father in heaven we thank you very
much for all that you do for us and we
ask that you also enlighten our minds
bless the discussion the viewers and all
listeners of this episode in jesus name
amen amen
martin we need to understand where we
stand in the stream of history
and
if we do not learn from history
then we will not understand the present
and we are prone to repeat it yes and no
we are doomed
to repeat it
so if we go to the signs of the end
then we read in matthew 24
and as he sat upon the mount of olives
the disciples came unto him privately
saying tell us
when shall these things be and what
shall be the sign of thy coming and of
the end of the world
and jesus answered and said unto them
take heed that no man deceive you
so this is a double prophecy for then
and for
the end of the world obviously one of
the signs
and what will it be like at the end of
the world and the number one problem
will be deception yeah
we've spoken about lies many times
surely we have inherited lies
and i think we are hearing lies every
single day
and the media is very good at
making propaganda out of lies yes it's
prevalent now it's so important because
i think the whole world is asleep
because they fall for all this it's time
to switch off the television and switch
on the brain yes
so if we look here at the signs of the
times then i think we must place them in
categories so the signs of the times can
be placed in various categories
and each category needs to come to
fruition and they need to climax
simultaneously before the full prophetic
picture can be realized
now what are these categories you know
people look at matthew 24 and say you
know earthquakes have always been
earthquakes
and pestilences there have always been
pestilences how do you know that this is
you know the end all right there's an
escalation that's it
but even that you know there were times
when there were escalations in the past
now there must be many many things which
must occur simultaneously
and this is what makes the prophetic
pictures are complete so if we look at
them they must be the physical
environmental signs that need to reach a
universal application
there must be moral decay associated
with end-time prophecies and they need
to be universal
yes you know if you read in the bible it
tells us what the world will be like in
the last days and how the youth will be
and
disobedience and
all of these things anarchy and violence
and
every imagination of the heart
continuously evil right
so there must be moral liquid decay and
then there must be ethnic clashes and
they must be commonplace and they must
be universal
and then there must be a political
prophetic picture that must come to
fruition
then there must be a religious prophetic
picture that must come to fruition
and then you need the legislation
associated with buying and selling and
the implementation of the mark of the
beast
and all of these collectively must be in
place at the same time yes then you know
you're in the in the last days
and i'm happy to announce that they are
all alive and doing well in the times
that we are living in
definitely the sooner the better yes it
has to come to fruition now
so let's have a look at the physical
environmental signs that need to
reach universal application
we already read in matthew 24 that when
jesus was on the mount of olives the
disciples came to him and they asked him
these things
and he answered
take heed that no man deceive you
deception will be the name of the game
so you have to
you have to study
how do you unearth deception
by studying and by studying
that's the thing that's happening now
nobody is studying they just
taking whatever is being told them
correct so the only ones as that man
already so correctly said
in rulers of evil in the forward the
only ones who believe in conspiracy
theories of those who have really
studied them right and those who shout a
lot are obviously totally ignorant as
far as these things are concerned
they've never read
things like morals and dogma they've
never read
blavatsky's writings
isis unveiled or secret doctrine they've
never read one of those thank god they
haven't because i wouldn't want to
you know
suggest that people read those books but
even books that are written about these
things to expose them the secret history
of the jesuits i've got a whole
stack of books
just on the history of the jesuits
the most evil society that has ever
disgraced this planet and it's not me
saying this alone
history has recorded it presidents have
said it the spirit of prophecy makes no
bones about it either
and
people say you know what is this all
about yes and then when we say people
prominent people are affiliated with the
jesuits yes
there's hardly a politician
who is high up in the ranks that is not
associated
and if he's not associated he could
probably end up being a dead politician
right yeah
so
let us not dwell on on the ignorance of
many but you must take heed you must
study
for many shall come in my name saying i
am christ and shall deceive many so when
you see people saying you know this is
it
there have always been those that have
claimed
that they are christ but then it was
always a sect somewhere over there
hidden away
whereas today this is
becoming world news
then you know well this is a different
level right
you'll hear of wars and rumors of wars
and these things must come to pass but
the end is not yet
nation shall rise against nation
kingdom against kingdom famines
pestilence earthquakes
and these are just the beginnings
so these are signs but then you must add
the political signs you must add the
religious signs you must add the moral
signs you must add
all of these things
so let's have a look at some of these
religious news services reported that
the messiah of the second coming has
come for easter 2021.
so
he's here
for easter
2021. that was quite a few months ago
well fortunately it was only a sort of a
zoom conference
so in the past palm sander chi chin
messiah the messiah of the second coming
hosted the teleconference of the second
coming to announce the first part
of the proclamation of the second coming
for the new millennium
to unveil the 2000 year mystery of the
book of revelation that's you know it's
amazing
so
here we have the israel today jewish
world top rabbi messiah's name will soon
be revealed now it becomes public right
yes
world news like you just said it's world
news and it's associated with the
rabbinical system and there they are
so
this rabbi revealed that god is ready to
reveal the name of the messiah and he
urged them to get ready and we need some
unity yes interesting to me if he's
ready to reveal the name
then it must be an earthly person
correct
and again if we have to do a little
summary
you know here at the end of the year we
need to do a few where we
pertinently summarize the events
just to make sure that we know where we
are standing in the stream of time and
this is now the first one
in that little series
is another israel today israeli rabbi
says he's already holding meetings with
the messiah
this is
pretty blatant right yeah
all right we don't have to go into all
of this we've mentioned it before in
other lectures
but he's considered one of the three top
rabbis of the ultra-orthodox jewish
community in israel so these are not
fly by night people these are prominent
people
saying the messiah is here
so that's a sign right yeah then we have
rumors of wars
and we have wars well we've had enough
wars yeah the war the world in fact
hasn't been without war and if you take
all the conflicts in africa and
all over the place and
then what are the chances of a bigger
war is a war with china inevitable this
is from the nation in july 2021
statement coming out of the department
of the defense and the upper congress
these days make it seem that way
so on this basis the pentagon requested
billion in military expenditures for
2022.
so this is
uh for a high intensity war with china
that will cost quite a lot of money and
you know china's in the news now a lot
yeah and also when they um
had that missile that hypersonic missile
that
there's a lot of buzz going on and the
navy is now bigger than the u.s navy and
don't put
russia out of the equation correct
russia is massing troops on the
ukrainian border
and they are speaking of a impending
invasion
and uh is it worthwhile for the united
states to defend ukraine or should they
they rather not risk that conflict and
china has now
sent aircraft into
the taiwanese airspace and they used
refueling planes for the first time
so you know these things are hurting up
but at this stage it's rumors of wars
but that's a fulfillment of prophecy
and these are not small wars we're
talking about
major nuclear confrontations exactly
the u.s and china are preparing for war
and australia is caught in the
crosshairs
this comes from the international
affairs analyst stan grant
and
there were big celebrations in china
because of the korean war where they say
china came out victorious
and therefore there's no reason why they
shouldn't be victorious again
all right so this is all part of the
picture
and then there will be
environmental calamities
and we showed this little video before
we can just
briefly click through it
so martin what's your comment on that
well it just shows you that
it is escalating right around the world
it's not just okay there's a little
storm here or here and there's always
been storms or there's always been
hurricanes that like you've mentioned
the intensity is picking up drastically
it's also possible that some people say
you know the
the population has moved into
dangerous areas
and the media is also picking up
dangerously so
whatever happens well that now you've
got
these two at juxtaposition
god said that it will increase and now
we've got it's because of climate change
correct
so there must always be a secular reason
and i guess job also thought it was
climate change
when his house and his children were
swept away right imagine what climate
change it was when noah
that was climate change of a real high
order where did it come from
and then as far as earthquakes are
concerned
they say that they are increasing in
frequency
and that they're increasing in intensity
so here's the report that the haiti
earthquake was twice as strong as the
2010 disaster which
actually claimed more lives than the
present one
there's a six-fold increase in people
suffering famine-like conditions since
the pandemic began this is interesting
this is also from 2021
11 people are likely dying every minute
from hunger now outpacing covet 19
fatalities warns oxfam
so
the hunger virus is multiplying crisis
levels of food insecurity
it's interesting that there was a news
not just
this week
that biden was supposed to hold a news
conference
on food security and supply lines
but then of course a new
virulent virus that gives you mild
tiredness
caused the whole world to shut down but
we'll talk about that in
another one
so
that is going to also cause a crisis
and we had this disaster in vancouver
and the government said please don't
hoard food the supply lines won't be
affected
so all of these things are pretty
pretty interesting right i'm sure a lot
of people have realized that supply
lines has actually been affected i think
so
and bill gate issued a stark warning for
the world as awful as this pandemic is
climate change could be worse
and he wants to darken the sun
instead of
feeding some of those hungry mouths
let's darken the sun
and uh the governments are all on board
and we've had a whole series on that so
we don't have to say too much about cop
26 and all of these things
but for the sake of
clarity and completeness let's just
listen again to what john kerry had to
say
and he's the one in charge of the
american response to climate change
right
the stakes on climate change just simply
couldn't be any higher than they are
right now
it is existential we use that word too
easily we throw it away
but we have a big agenda in front of us
on a global basis
and president biden
is deeply committed totally seized by
this issue as you can tell by this
executive order he also knows that paris
alone is not enough
not when almost 90 percent
of all of the planet's emissions global
emissions come from outside of u.s
borders we could go to zero tomorrow
and the problem isn't solved
so that's why today one week into the
job president biden
will sign this additional executive set
of orders
to help move us down the road ensuring
that ambitious
climate action is
global
in scope and scale as well as
the national here at home the president
is announcing that he will host a
leaders summit on climate change less
than three months from now
on april 22 earth day
which will include a leader level
reconvening of the major economies forum
to the convening of this
uh of this summit
is essential to ensuring
that the
that 2021 is going to be the year that
really makes up for the lost time of the
last four years
and that the un climate conference cop
26 as it's called which the uk is
hosting in november
to make sure that it is an unqualified
success
so martin just to put that into
perspective
we have
all of this hype in the world
and
we know that the bible predicts
that there will be natural disasters
we also know
that there are statements
in the spirit of prophecy which says
that there are demonic forces also
working behind the scenes
to manipulate
and
we must also remember that they use
humanity in order to manipulate that's
it
they're agents correct and we know for a
fact
that climate can be manipulated exactly
because a lot of people say that's
conspiracy no no no they've admitted
this top scientist and we've had
last year episode on that
there's definitely
clima
climate manipulation going on correct
and not only climate manipulation
that can create earthquakes
tesla created
equipment that could create earthquakes
and that equipment is still
available
and can be viewed
in the united states of america
so
let's just have a quick reality check
again
the climate models that they used are
exactly those they're based on models
and there are many many models and they
all predict this tremendous climb
in temperature
and
it seems as if all the governments use
models a handful of models to do this
and we've had scientists in our past
programs
speaking on these issues and say
that these models are really
thumbnailogy
sucking it out of your thumb
because this blue line here is reality
and the fluctuations in the blue line
are in accordance with the events that
have happened through the centuries
so again
is this reality or is this hype
and thousands of scientists literally
thousands have signed documents stating
that this is nothing but propaganda and
hype
be careful
unless someone leads you
in a direction that you might not want
to go with some ulterior motive exactly
least you be deceived correct
now
here is a video martin which is
interesting because it's on cnn
and
the founder of the weather channel there
and his deceased now already he made an
interesting little
hoo-ha
on television
because he he was no longer involved at
that stage and he got quite uh
angry
and it's interesting as to what he had
to say now people will say you know
that's past history now we know that
this is a real fact this climate change
but there are thousands of scientists
who will assert the opposite exactly but
then we have banning and shadow banning
don't we that's it
so let's just look at this little
interview because it's quite interesting
one of the biggest crises we face
climate change and a media war over that
crisis
climate deniers people who believe
climate change is not happening in any
meaningful way are sometimes painted in
the media as fringe characters as kooks
so this might shock you
a man who co-founded the weather channel
thinks climate change is a hoax
so what did the weather channel do it
very publicly disavowed him after all
for those who believe that the climate
is changing and fast this is a life and
death matter
it's nice to be on cnn hello to all your
viewers i resent you calling me a denier
that is a word meant to put me down i'm
a skeptic about climate change and i
want to make it darn clear mr kenny's
not a scientist i am he's the ceo of the
weather channel now i was the founder of
the weather channel not the co-founder
and i'm glad you did because i am
addicted to the weather channel i
watched a lot of people now hold on just
a minute i'm not done
and cnn has taken a very strong position
on global warming that is that it is a
consensus well there is no consensus in
science science isn't a vote science is
about facts and if you get down to the
hard cold facts
there's no question about it climate
change is not happening there is no
significant
man-made global warming now there hasn't
been any in the past and there's no
reason to expect any in the future
there's a whole lot of baloney and yes
it is has it has become
a big political point of the democratic
party and part of their platform and i
regret it's become political instead of
scientific but the science is on my side
i don't think we're going to come to the
conclusion about the topic right here
what i do wonderfully
because you wouldn't allow it to happen
on cnn but i'm happy that i got on the
air and i got a chance to talk to your
uh to your viewers hello everybody what
is no global warming what i do wonder is
when you see the government when you see
nasa when you see other institutions say
that 97 of climate scientists agree
do you think they're making it up but
what i don't understand is how you but
it's a manipulative figure and let me
explain it to you
uh this the government puts out about
two and a half billion dollars directly
for climate research every year
it only gives that money to scientists
who will produce scientific results that
support the global warming hypothesis of
the democrat party a position
so
they don't have any choice
if you're going to get the money you got
to support their position therefore 97
of the scientific reports published
support global warming why because those
are the ones the government pays for and
that's where the money is it's real
simple but that doesn't mean it's right
that doesn't make it true
that only makes it bought and paid for
the money goes in circles i'm not a
scientist so i'm not going to try to
refute that's the truth i'll simply say
that
from this issue and let the two sides be
on the air there are 31 000 scientists
who have signed a petition that says it
is it is not valid that my position is
correct and we'll keep battling and we
we will prevail in time but i don't know
if we'll do it in my lifetime
martin do we have to add anything to
that i don't think it's necessary i
don't think it's necessary all right
he's just one of them right there were
others as well
and some of them were quite humorous
especially when they were taking al gore
to task and climbing up and down ladders
trying to make their point
so you know we can go on and on in
circles there are two sides to a story
and when one side is constantly put down
and facts checked and told that they are
a lunatic fringe how many did he mention
there 31 000
i mean that's that's incredible all
right not all of them were
climatologists
but but many of them had phds in the
half of them 15 000 that's quite a
substantial amount of scientists and i
can promise you the 97 percent that
agreed with it that he was mentioning in
that one were not 15 000. no
and just another comment that i would
like to make
it's again coming back to logic
i think a lot of logic is also missing
when you have when you're discussing
these things it's it's about emotion
and getting a particular agenda on board
we've discussed that agenda in some
detail in the past
we're not just looking at signs but
here's an interesting article from the
deutsche vision
that's the german science news
groundbreaking verdict
and this comes from 11 11 2021. for the
first time the court finds that wind
turbines are harmful to your health for
the first time the existence and
significance of the so-called wind
turbine syndrome is recorded
i.e harmful consequences of the low
frequency noise emitted by wind turbines
and infrasound on health
the judgment of the court of appeal
could have far-reaching consequences for
the development of wind power in germany
and europe
you know whenever you do something
there is a problem if you have overhead
power lines
you're advised not to live underneath
them because you have a higher incidence
of cancer
you cannot just shut down everything
but you cannot necessarily
replace everything with with something
else that's a thing i mean if you take a
a while years back
you had the
whole of the ozone
and then they got rid of all the cfcs if
i remember correct since then you
haven't heard of any problem with those
but now that has created another problem
again
so now
they in the lower atmosphere there's
some problem that they have to get rid
of now
so it will always you'll just shift it's
almost like when you get a disease and
you try to cure it with with a with a
drug with a drug you're just
putting it in another place
correct so this thing will carry on and
on and on and whatever your agenda is
you can fit it into the into the
narrative right
the spectator are you ready for climate
lockdowns so now we've
we've ranked it up or racked it up to
such a level
that the possibility of climate
lockdowns is already being floated by
some of our greatest thinkers i've
become rather allergic to some of our
greatest thinkers haven't you
yes
under climate lockdown governments would
limit private vehicle use ban
consumption of red meat and impose
extreme energy saving measures while
fossil fuel companies would have to stop
drilling
to avoid such a scenario we must
overhaul our economic structures and do
capitalism differently this sounds
exactly like the vatican
[Music]
so bill gates as we have said before
wants to spray dust into the atmosphere
so that he can block the sun does he
know what the consequences might be
elsewhere
as a has a environmental impact study
being done on that has the science come
out or will the science be just as
one-sided as it is at the moment i'm
sure and what's scary is i think they're
actually going forward with it
and now they want environmental
activists pushing for compulsory climate
change education worldwide as part of
the paris agreement
well you know there's
many things that they want to change in
education
sex education is changing in the world
and parents have no say as to what the
children but that's a moral issue we'll
come to that
now you have environmental
activists wanting to give
environmental classes
now what about those 31 000 scientists
will any one of them be
eligible for a job like that no i don't
i don't think so right
no it'll be the others
so obviously that which was has to be
removed the entire economy has to be
restructured
and when it is restructured the money
will go into
that which the government favors right
yes
so the middleman will be again
cut out
and the middle class will disappear
small business we'll be back in the
middle ages
so
let these people build back
better
build back better to build back better
or whatever and build back better to
build back better build back from this
uh global pandemic build back better
build back better building back better
to build back better build it back
better and build it back better build
back better to build back build back
better it's about building this country
back
better build back better
building back better build
back
better some would say to build back
battle we would say to really have a
grease and great reset
the cartoonists are having a field day
political cartoon of the day plugging
the pipeline plug back better
it's interesting when they depict him
these days he's always got blood on his
hand
and
not much going on upstairs
now
you know i think this is
being a bit facetious perhaps
i don't think that it's as bad as they
portray
but when i listen to his latest speeches
on
the new pandemic and the new variants
and the flip-flopping that takes place
there i sometimes wonder
whether you know not only he but many
others whether all the ganglia are
operating at optimal capacity
or are they just very good at doing what
they're told
perhaps perhaps they're all trained
actors
after all many of them have been to
jesuit
schools and universities and their
acting becomes a very prominent part of
the curriculum jesuit theater
now one of the more serious issues
because
this is the reason why
god
has to draw a line
because when morality becomes so debased
that all the imagination is continuously
evil
then then it's time for god to act
because they've made void his law
so moral decay associated with the end
time prophecy needs to be
universal
and this debate really has become
california law
would find department stores a thousand
dollars for separating toys by
gender children now need time to decide
what gender they are
so you don't have a blue room and a pink
room anymore
you have a neutral room until you know
what gender it is
now anybody with
that is even slightly compass mentors
used to know immediately once the child
was born
what gender it was
and nowadays with ultrasound you know
what gender it is before they're even
born
but martin
that seems to have gone out of the
window i wonder which brilliant
scientist figured this out
unfortunately
this is the norm
this is the norm and the standard yeah
so in the schools in the united states
of america they have gender neutral
restrooms
and there have been some very serious
incidents because that is quite uh
a carrot
that is dangled before some people to
assume an agenda that suits their agenda
right yeah it's a scary scenario when
you start going into these things
it is in actual fact a total
loss of cognizance yeah it's moral decay
it's moral decay of the highest order
gay poly
morris trouble with children say it's no
big deal
that their kids have three dads
and
you know one wonders
what the consequences will be long term
if you do not have
this balance
of
a father and a mother and the bible
clearly says he created them male
and female that seems to be banned these
days and it's not only the united states
whether you go to the uk whether you go
to other parts of europe whether you go
to the pacific region australia new
zealand
africa it doesn't matter where
this let's call it by its name disease
has become universal it is a universal
model
decay
everything that god has put in place
that order has been
turned upside down once again by the
master of reversal correct
and uh you know
this this whole push of role reversal
and you know let's talk about this for a
little while
you know the the people think that the
division of labor between a male and a
female
is such that
the woman is getting the short straw
in actual fact when you read the bible
she got the higher responsibility
the man had to go out
and earn the keep by the sweat of his
brow
and her desire would be for him
people pervert that that verse as well
because
this obviously created a separation
he's out there and she's dealing with
the other issues raising
children with moral characters that is
the highest
job
in the universe
the highest job in the universe has been
given to the woman
and
it's not that a man can't do it
you have single dads and sometimes
circumstances force these things upon
you
but
you still need both to have
that balance and the world is in a in a
sad state because of sin
but if we would be
happy with the roles that god has
assigned us
the world would be a better place
key facts on abortion if you look at
these statistics it's absolutely
horrifying
an abortion is a medical procedure that
ends a pregnancy it is a basic health
care need for millions of women
girls and others
who can become pregnant worldwide
an estimated one in four pregnancies end
in an abortion every year that's a
quarter
of
the increase to humanity a quarter
it's a lot of people yes and
99.99
of those are nothing short but murder
and you know is it a fetus or is it
a human being
the bible calls it and the child
the child jumped within the womb
so this is this is a moral issue that
this is a moral issue and god will hold
the world accountable
for
the reasons for this what is the main
reason
why
this has become so important it's
because of moral decay yes
because of moral decay
u.s bishops court funding radical groups
supporting riots calling for death to
the police now you have the church
adding its voice to
ethnic violence
now that's another sign of the times
now martin
god has created
the bible says
the whole of humanity by one blood
correct
and therefore
as god's children
we are all of one blood therefore we are
brothers and sisters
but humanity has so separated them into
groups and now we have all kinds of new
groups as well
artificial groups
and then you have draconian rules
coming in to enforce these artificial
groups
this is all part of moral decay
definitely a total disregard to the
value of life
and the value of a person of whatever
race or creed they come from
and in god in christ we are all
one and if we
implement
love your neighbor
then you won't have this problem you
won't have this problem but this problem
is being fueled
by what by propaganda that's it
and the propaganda machine unfortunately
is universal that's it and people fall
for this
you're not and that's where i think it's
important if you're grounded in the
bible
then propaganda like this in the media
won't affect you but it's sad to say
that even in the church people have been
affected
because
the propaganda machine actually caught
them correct now
at pentecost
was there segregation in those that
received the gift of the holy spirit no
no
and when those thousands were baptized
did they put them into categories no
they put them into black white waxed
unwaxed whatever did they categorize
them no no that's exactly what
god intended for it that the holy spirit
will be poured out on all did they say
did they separate them into
20 or 30 genders no no absolutely not
right
so black lives matter is a spiritual
movement says the co-founder patrice
colors
why because they have ancestor worship
in there now we know what the bible says
about that be careful lest anyone
deceives you this is deception of the
highest order because the bible says the
dead know nothing they were asleep
so how can you introduce them in this
way you see it now the problem is
you because you might um associate with
some of this
swallow the pull
and then you sit and you become exactly
what the bible warns you against so
you're drinking a soft drink with
arsenic in it
and who becomes your enemy
anybody that doesn't look or
think like you exactly that's the enemy
so this martin
is not a color issue this is a moral
issue
this is a moral issue
it is a
devaluation a degradation
an atrocity
against what god says in his word it is
a direct affront to what god has
revealed in his word because over and
over
it says even in the book of revelation
every tribe and tongue and people it
doesn't matter
what happens is here
modern
the media do they play a role in this
model
decay i think they are at the head of
the moral victory right the movie world
in the old south africa when i was
young
they had a sensor board
i'm the only one who got to watch the
moral decay
where those who were in the center board
and they were mostly of a religious
nature right
they were the pastors etc those poor
people they became so perverted probably
they didn't know which way to go anymore
but nowadays everything goes it's all
right all right and how they target
children
it is a a form of moral decay which we
would never have expected possible
here's a little discussion on how they
advertise things
john lewis recently released an ad for
home insurance featuring a young boy
wearing
for allowing your kid to trash your home
maybe if john lewis had actually
concentrated on the details of their
service rather than their effusive zeal
to portray a buoyant lipstick the ad
wouldn't have been banned but it's not
really about the product anymore is it
this year's halloween ad for twix
chocolate bar features a boy facing
discrimination for wearing a princess
dress a witch nanny then comes to the
boy's aid after he's confronted by a
bully
hey you
princess
you look like a girl why are you wearing
that the witch nanny then conjures up a
magic trick to disappear the bully so
parents leave a kid alone until the new
nanny comes she forces herself in then
murders a playground boy oh cause he
said they look different you sure this
will help us sell more twix twix last
year the nhs terrified children by
showing santa being wheeled into the
hospital on the verge of dying of covid
heineken the beer company that proudly
supports the total abolition of all
borders at least remains consistent by
insisting that there shouldn't be any
borders when it comes to public toilets
but only if you've had your shot and
displayed your vaccine passport
granddad dies goes to heaven and comes
back as a gay ghost
[Music]
oh
are you sure this will help us sell more
doritos doritos look at this charmingly
quaint snapshot of suburban british life
[Music]
bear in mind this is an ad for bingo
has the world gone mad or has it gone
mad martin
it's not about like you said it's not
about the it's selling the product
anymore no it's about selling diversity
right
it's to make it acceptable exactly
now
what about the political prophetic
picture that must come to fruition as
well right
the kings of the world must give their
power unto the beast
so when we read in the book of
revelation and we've dealt with this in
many many lectures this is just a
summary lecture
we know that there will be a healing of
the papal wound because i saw one of the
heads were wounded to death and his
deadly wound was healed
and then he beheld this other beast come
up out of the earth
this two-horned beast
statecraft churchcraft will come
together and they will make an image to
the first beast become like it speak
like it
and introduce draconian laws
which honor the first beast right
and
there will be miracles and signs
which will seem to portray the idea
that the religious
world is on the right track here
in doing what it is doing by uniting
with government
to enforce certain legislation look
biblical it will look that this is what
god wants this is what god wants and
there's no denying
that we have all of these issues
happening in the world today
that require draconian legislation even
to the point of a death sentence because
it is for the common good for the common
good
so it deceives them that dwell on the
earth by means of those miracles which
he had power to do in the sight of the
beast
saying to them that dwell on the earth
that they should make an image to the
beast which had the wound by the sword
and did live
now the first beast roman catholicism
where all the reformers were united on
this idea
this is a
summation of the identity of the
antichrist which they identified as the
papacy
it lost its political power
in 1798
when under the french revolution which
by the way
was steered by the jesuits napoleon was
educated by the jesuits he was one of
their key men
took hold of the whole situation ended
the political power in 1929 they gave it
back to the vatican in a new form
and uh since then we've had
this great march back into political
power oh definitely i mean
the influence of the vatican correct
it's just gone
today we have a roman catholic
president in the united states who makes
no bones about it and his whole team
even john kerry saying
the moral power that we must
make an image of is the paper scene
and i saw one of the heads as it were
wounded to death and his deadly wound
was healed and all the world wandered
after the beast and this word means
admire
well if you look at some of the speeches
isn't he treated with admiration
at the highest there's no person on
earth that's treated with a higher
admiration than him
so now this is the political picture
that must come to fruition so you must
have the moral decay which we've seen
we must have the environmental chaos
which we've seen
we must have the messianic chaos which
we've seen
and now we must have the political issue
the wound
must have been given 1798
the wound must start to heal 29 1929 he
gets back his political power
and then
through his agents which are the jesuits
and the knights of malta and the knights
of columbus political organizations they
infiltrate the political systems of the
world and the kings of the world are
basically
just doing the bidding of these powers
that operate behind the scenes
as a result the world admires the papacy
and the political world is seen to unite
with it it was totally separated
when the united states of america was
formed when
the colonies were formed they were
protestant colonies
and eventually they became independent
protestant nations
that's all over gone the political world
has changed
and there came one of the seven angels
which had the seven vials
and talked with me
saying unto me come heather and i will
show unto thee the judgment of the great
that sits on many waters
now martin this angel that has one of
the seven vials
those vials contain the lost plagues
yeah
so he's already ready to pour out the
last plagues
and here he is
and he's saying i'll show you the
judgment of this great religious
apostate system because that's what a
is in the bible it is a system of
apostasy against the word of god
that sits on many waters and the bible
defines the waters as peoples multitudes
nations and kings
so this great church
which sits upon
many waters
is also depicted in this chapter as a
woman riding the beast
that means she controls it she contrail
controls the political systems of the
world
with whom
the kings of the earth have committed
fornication they have admired her
for a false doctrine
they have drunk the wine of her
fornication
and the inhabitants of the earth
are also drunk with the wine of her
fornication they get her fornication
via the media from morning till night
and drink it hook line and sinker
it's a rather sad state of affairs
take heed that's it
that no one
deceive you
and one of the heads said revelation 13
was as it was wounded to death and the
deadly wound was healed
that means it has political clout back
and all the world wandered after the
beast
right all the world
wandered admired the beast
in other words they had made an image to
it
and they were going to be like it and
god warned us
don't do it
whatever comes out of that beast's mouth
is a lie yes it's so important to know
that yes because what is the mouthpiece
of the beast the media media the media
it controls the media
because through its knights of columbus
and other affiliates it has
total control
of all of these things so let's just
give this brief overview again we've
done it before the kings of the world
whether they are from the right or
whether they are from the left it makes
no difference this is where they go
whether they are from the communist
block or whether they are from the
capitalist block
they are good buddies i mean these two
people seem to know each other quite
well don't they
they look like long friends who haven't
seen each other for a long time and this
one over here
well
he seems to have a very intimate
relation
and he's made no bones about it and
jesuit trained right yeah most of them
most of them
unbelievable that all of these things
should come to fruition in our time
now
the media and the great internet
companies
tim cook ceo of apple
or what about mark zuckerberg
or what about kevin systrom ceo of
instagram why they all there martin
it's interesting
once they've been there
do we see a lot of changes all of the
sudden coming into
all of this correct now look at this
young man
over here
or this one over here
what are they doing at the vatican
and why
do all the rules change as soon as they
put their foot out of the vatican right
so there's a lot of planning that's
going on so whatever is shadow band is
something that's probably the truth and
everything that is on alternative media
is probably more truthful than what is
on actual media
let's be
quite open and blunt about this
if science
or any other
area of endeavor
is not permitted
to have alternative views aired so that
you can weigh them in a balance then
it's no longer science it's called
propaganda and coercion
perfect that's exactly what it is
and the religious world
whether
they are from the pentecostal world or
what about the father of
so-called protestantism this day rick
warren or what about the head of the
lutheran world federation they all seem
very happy to return did any of the
doctrines of rome change no
then what reason is there to embrace
them
because
they have been
deceived
they have been deceived they have been
indoctrinated
they have swallowed the wine
correct
now remember when joe biden went to
visit the pope just before cop
and he had that meeting also then in
rome with the g20 countries
where they made all kinds of agreements
as i suddenly heard of over the news the
other day
that apparently aren't being adhered to
and he gave gifts
to the pope and he arrived with 85
vehicles that all had to be flown in
armoured vehicles
that guzzle a huge amount of fuel
to make sure that he contributes
liberally to climate change parameters
and he gave gifts and it's interesting
that the gift was something that was
very dear to the jesuits
so let's have a look at this
a motorcade of 85 vehicles escorted
president joseph biden and first lady
jill biden to the vatican on friday
morning for a private meeting with pope
francis a day before the g20 summit of
world leaders in rome it was the first
time joe biden met the pope as president
of the united states
biden is the second catholic u.s
president in history and he fittingly
chose a rather catholic gift for the
pope it was this hand-woven fiddleback
chasible from the archival collection of
the holy trinity church in washington dc
the vestment was commissioned in 1930
and used by the jesuits in the united
states
i hope you find this gift from the
united states appropriate
the pope in turn gave the president a
one-of-a-kind ceramic depicting a
pilgrim in rome with saint peter's
basilica in the background he also gave
him a collection of his pontifical texts
don't you find it interesting
that he says i hope that you will find
this gift from the united states
acceptable yes and it it comes from the
jesuits and there were some
presidents of the united states that
vehemently
spoke against against the jews correct
and they want that should those
sentiments ever be adopted
that would be
the new night
and i think we are having a new night in
the world do you have the image and the
beast there together you have everything
together so it's god's plan to unite all
of humanity
but it seems to me that this unity of
all humanity must be on the basis of
their morality
which is totally contrary to the
biblical morality
here's the
the section in
genesis where it deals with the tower of
babel
and it is quite clear
that when that happened the whole earth
was one language and one speech
we could say today they are marching in
unison with one way of thinking
and it came to pass as they journeyed
from the east that they found a plane in
the land of shinar
and they dwelt there that's babylon
and they said one to another go let us
make brick and burn them thoroughly
and they had brick for stone and slime
bitumen asphalt
had they for mortar and they said go let
us build us a city
and a tower
whose top may reach unto heaven and let
us make us a name
lest we be scattered abroad upon the
face of the whole earth
but there was a direct denial of the
veracity of a promise that god had made
he said i will not destroy the world
again they disbelieved god exactly so
these are the ones that believe the
serpent rather than believing god
and they want to build a city
now babylon was a city and anti-typical
babylon is a city
and rome calls itself the mother city
the city
so this is all very fascinating they're
building a new tower of babel and they
make no bones about it they even put it
on their emblems in europe
that it is the new tower of babel
so the religious prophetic picture must
also come to fruition and we've seen
this unity
and this economical drive
now just to elaborate a little
if this is an apostate system you must
see it clearly
because there should be no room for
deception because god wants to be fair
right
so amazonian woman who led the vatican
tree planting ceremony reveals the pagan
significance of what they did
and they basically knelt down before
pachamama
and this is a goddess an earth goddess
ritual right yeah this is ben theism
pantheism in its highest form and
idolatry
yes and the pope participates and the
protestant churches what did they say
nothing nothing nothing maybe a squawk
here and a squawk there there were more
from the
right
side in catholicism that were actually
making some waves okay
so search for christian unity is making
progress says the pope so obviously
christian unity must be unity in error
yeah right you have to get rid of
something to get unity
marking the 25th anniversary of sin
john paul ii encyclical on christian
unity
pope francis said he shares the healthy
impatience of those who think more can
and should be done
but he also insisted that christians
must be grateful for the progress that
has already been made
and of course it's taken centuries and
millennia because this rift between the
orthodox church and rome
has taken uh quite a while right yeah
so here we go
they're coming together is this a sign
of the times
definitely
the wound must be
healed
was there a wound when protestant isn't
separated from rome yes
all right and they called it
children
the children will return to the mother
right
do we see children returning to the
mother yes in droves now before the
protestant reformation were there
children
no
no actually
no there were no children right
so obviously the children must come
after
they'd been spawned yeah yeah correct
so now the children will return to the
mother
now why did they separate from the
because they weren't in harmony with the
scripture exactly have they come into
harmony with the scripture in the
meantime no no they've gone worse right
and that's why they could go back
so now they've gone back so what does
that mean
about the children that the children
become better or did they become worse
worse
i see
the bible calls her the mother of
harlots that's it
so what if the children become then
or become harlot
why how could they become harlots what
have they done to become harlots if you
tolerate error yes you're a horror you
are a holland
if you
sit at the same table
and partake of the same spiritual food
then you are a harlot
so this is a rather sad set of affairs
it's a sign of the times
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
so martin this is a very clever little
video
that's been put out by the vatican with
the pope as the
narrator and he's showing the various
religions
in their own sphere
and then he shows their commonality
they have a food kitchen
and they hand out food standing side by
side to the poor
martin
is that the gospel or should that be a
fruit of the gospel a fruit of the
gospel okay so we're not denying that
it's
that it's not right to give food to
those who are hungry
but
that is their commonality
so martin
it seems to me
that
social issues
are the commonality everything that has
to do with the common good
common good which is defined by him
which obviously must also be based on a
lie because he is
from the father of lies right the dragon
gave him his power
so all of this is coming together are we
in the last days
if you cannot see this then i think it's
time to open your eyes
i think so too now martin how far do
they want to take this imagery just
within the christian world or with the
others as well no that has to
incorporate all
so we're going to build
abrahamic family house in abu dhabi
let's build one in berlin as well let's
build one in new york yes
now
do
these religions
that have a common ancestry according to
them namely abraham
do they all have a common belief in who
the messiah is and what his role is no
so what will be their cultural unity
what we saw previously right
so rotten this is a sign of the times
you know it's interesting
by one name can you
achieve heaven yes
and that name is messina
it has to be missing otherwise you can't
have this unity and even if they use the
name like the judaism uses messiah and
catholicism uses jesus christ and so on
it's not the one of the bible no it's a
different one a completely different one
now
the bible also tells us when this wound
is healed the second beast will make an
image to the beast right
in other words it will have its mindset
well they've made it quite clear that
they have its mindset already
but here crooks reported that if biden
is to heal america he'll need his church
now is this church and state working
together to heal something well i can't
think that you can have it more
bluntly that it's church and state
working together
absolutely so is this a sign of the
times definitely
then finally the legislation associated
with buying and selling and the
implementation of the mark of the beast
needs to be in place
that's the final sign right getting
everything in place for the fire
now the mark of the beast has to do with
the authority of the beast
versus the authority of god the mark of
the beast as opposed to the seal of god
and the seal something that seals
something into law if you put your seal
on it then that was law
you'll find it in the ten commandments
in six days the lord
there's his name
his title
creator god who made the heavens and the
earth his jurisdiction heaven and earth
that's his seal is in the sabbath
commandment rome says no i've changed
that
my seal is in the sunday exactly it's
like when you take the nine commandments
without the fourth one that's the seal
any god could have done could have
claimed that correct but to put the
proof on which god it is
creator of everything there's a step
correct now as soon as you put the sun
day
the venerable day of the sun in its
place that's sun worship
and the god of sun worship according to
the secret societies of the world is
lucifer yeah
and you can read morals and dogma by
albert pike or you could read mackie his
work on
freemasonry or you could read
blavatsky's writings
they make no bones about it that the god
that they worship is baal
the sun god
now baal worship was a major problem
when it came to the israelites
and ezekiel saw the vision of the 20
25 elders with their backs to the temple
worshiping the sun about 25 about 25.
and whenever you look at the imagery in
the world of worship they always have
their hands up towards the sun right
they're worshiping the
sun and the papacy
has the image of the sun coming out of
the golden cup
that is one of the images of the jesuit
order the golden cup with the sun circle
the host with the sun rays with the name
letters i h s on it
right those are
jesuit emblems they are emblems of
sun worship of lucifer worship
and these two
will come into conflict with each other
now in order to implement the mark of
the beast
you need to
implement buying and selling regulations
because if you do not go along with what
they tell you
you will be deprived of
any economic activity yes
in other words they will cut off your
lifeline right
what do you call that martin
coercion
correct
we've got this tuned down pat right
and it
also if we can just say it again it
won't happen then only when the mark of
the beast is being implemented because
that will be too obvious it has to come
before with other issues
so let's see
does
this legislation
have
the possibility of a rising in the
current climate
that is the final sign
well here's some news big business gets
its wings as leaders from major u.s
companies partner with pope francis
so big business
will now
implement certain rules as to who may be
economically active and who may not
and where did they get their wings after
they partnered with pope francis
it's an interesting statement right
so the alliance known as the council for
inclusive capitalism with the vatican
aims to create a more inclusive fair and
sustainable economic landscape
by taking pledges towards sustainable
development goals focused on areas such
as climate action peace and justice
quality education and gender equality
the whole catastrophe is in that one
sentence
if you don't have our moral mindset and
you don't comply
to our
rules and regulations
we will cut you off
do they have those rules in place yes
okay
no jab no job
vatican gets tough with covet
anti-vaxxers you know if you want to
lead you have to lead by example
they were the first ones to do it right
back in
february already all right is this
coercion oh definitely is this saying
you will not be able to buy or sell we
will cut you off
all right so the vatican
led by example
business maverick
no jab no job big business pushes for
mandatory covert vaccinations in the
workplace so
did big big business
follow
the vatican plan yes are they going to
build back better
what's going to happen to the little
middle man when all the finances go into
building back better for the mega
companies and everybody else goes on to
lock down
then they will finally have the entire
means
of making you do
what they want you to do that's it
you'll owe nothing and you'll be happy
you remember and you will have a
passport which shows your compliance and
obedience that's it a green light or a
red light and a red light so that's how
it will be
and this is not
speculation no it's happening all right
is this biblical yes
yes
button
are there environmental signs in place
is the moral decay in place
is the political world on board
is the religious world on board is the
economic world on board is the mechanism
in place
what other signs are we waiting for
martin
the final implementation of the mark of
the piers that's it now people will say
you always talk about it but it hasn't
happened but we've had talks about it
of how it what makes its way in darkness
and how it has been implemented
do you really think
that
the devil will put it out there
so that the whole world can know no but
he'll put it out in plain sight just
like the
secret societies do it but in so twisted
a fashion that most people don't see it
exactly and you will be deceived correct
so revelation 18 verse 23 in the light
of the candle shall shine no more at all
in thee
and the voice of the bridegroom and of
the bride shall be heard no more at all
in thee for thy merchants
were the great men of the earth
and by thy sorceries were all nations
deceived now sorceries is occultism
but it's also pharmacia
and the vatican through its
affiliates controls the medical world
the drug world
the medical drug world and the other
drug worlds as well just by the way
and they practice sorcery there's no
doubt about that because through their
secret societies and their affiliations
they are busy with sorcery
anton lavey
the founder of the church of satan and
the author of the satanic bible
found his most illustrious audience at
the university of san francisco which is
a jesuit institution and that is history
they make no bones about their dabbling
in the occult
and in their pharmacia and in her
this is a rather profound statement
was found the blood of the prophets
and of the saints
and of all that were slain upon the
earth
the multitudes of millions that have
died as a consequence of the system
will only be known in the judgment
but they
are
there according to this verse
the blood of all that was slain upon the
earth
there are
things happening in the world today
which are
leading to the death of thousands and
millions
and if we trace cause to effect then we
should take note of this verse
revelation 18 verse 24.
is the coronavirus pandemic a judgment
from god
well martin it depends what god you're
talking about
that's true is it a god of their own
creation
we will find out
here is yahoo news
medical journals warned world leaders
not to wait until covet 19 is over to
address the climate crisis
calling it the greatest threat to global
public health so martin we have to to
move from one crisis
which by the way
has been used to implement structures
that will prevent you from buying and
selling if you do not comply
to certain wishes exactly if they were
to two years ago implement
these structures that have now been
implemented
without a pandemic it would never
everybody would have kicked against us
you wouldn't have been able to do it but
isn't it interesting
that you go from a vaccination card to a
green card
what does that tell you
and what will be the next step
a a vaccination card a green card and a
mock card
that little green or red
flash that comes on your phone or card
or whatever
determine a lot
so
has this already happened
get ready for the left's climate change
emergency we're going to have a climate
crisis and it's going to be called code
red for the world
and now we've had the first case on the
member 8th 2021 where a canadian woman
becomes the first person diagnosed as
suffering from climate change
so is climate change going to be a
health issue definitely they've already
glued them together people are sick
because of climate change didn't pope
francis
himself say
that coronavirus came into existence
because of climate change he did
that is a fascinating statement a
fascinating statement totally devoid of
science but nevertheless a fascinating
statement
this is god's creation
so says pelosi
pelosi invokes religion for climate
change action after the un summit
this is very interesting it's a moral
obligation she says
for us to hand this planet over to the
next generation in a responsible way for
me it's a religious thing martin is
church and stayed together
i don't know how you cannot see this are
they talking the language of the bible
all this are all the signs of the times
in place
so what are we waiting for
the final act that's it
the last song
let's listen to her
in terms of the
investment in combating the climate
crisis
i think i've seen you since i was in
glasgow we had a delegation 22 members
our chairs
it took a giant step forward but we have
to do our share our fair share and so
what that's about is creating good pay
it's about health care for our children
cleaners about jobs jobs jobs good
paying union jobs to keep us preeminent
in green technologies throughout the
world you've heard me say it's a
national security issue as the national
security advisors tell us
a competition for and of course a moral
obligation for us to hand this planet
over to the next generation in a
responsible way for me it's a religious
thing i believe this is god's creation
and we have moral obligation to be good
stewards but if you don't share that
view you must share the view that we
have enough
that's a script straight out of
revelation yeah she put in the
labor unions even there the labor unions
are in their jobs jobs jobs through the
labor unions
this is incredible martin this is a
fulfillment of prophecy
and there are people who claim that
we are not there
be careful lest anyone
deceive you
here's the journal america from a
november issue in 2021
cop 26 did not go far enough it's time
to take the pope francis approach to
climate change
now that is admiring the first beast
right if you remember
francis also gave biden
as a gift his encyclicals
correct
to better understand the contrast we can
explore another pair of cities paris
where a climate accord was hammered out
in 2015 versus rome and its body of
catholic thought
they reveal vastly different
perspectives on climate change rome or
the catholic church begins rightly by
defining life's purpose and then
searches for socio-political structures
that will get us there
now rome has defined all the jesuits
have defined what life's purpose is
and according to richard m gula
the jesuit professor
life's purpose
is to live a truly human life
now martin i thought life's purpose was
to develop a moral character
in relationship with jesus christ
and accepting
his gift of salvation
so that you can be
fitted for heaven that was life's
purpose here's a totally new purpose
which is so mundane
and so earthly because they don't even
believe in the millennium they are a
millennialist
that it really is a travesty of justice
rome encourages us to use ignacian
spirituality
in other words a fake spirituality based
on the imagination rather than reality
your virtual reality your virtual
reality
to see god in all things pantheism while
instructing us that we are all stewards
of the earth
martin jesus said my kingdom is not of
this world if it were so my servants
would fight
but the day is coming
when all these signs are fulfilled that
he will come with power and great glory
and put an end to this misery
rome understands that virtue flows from
the pursuit of the common good
defined by solidarity
charity and the reciprocity
in other words you must all work
together
and the one that you must work together
with
is him yeah like that little video we
watched earlier correct
rome therefore informs the climate
change challenge on two levels
the epistemological
by properly framing the question and
identifying the root cause of the
problem
what is that
the roman document that most obviously
serves as the counterpoise to the paris
agreement is laudato c
but francis instructs us that all things
are connected and that climate change
social injustice and economic inequality
are
inextricably
linked
so martin's social injustice is causing
climate change
interesting
throughout the encyclical francis
explains how our idolatry of the machine
and our unbridled pursuit of narrow
self-interest crowd out any sense of
justice
and the common good
but what about his idolatry
his idolatry of pachamama what about his
idolatry of the mass
what about his idolatry of mixing truth
with error what about his idolatry of of
making void the law of god
what about all of those
they don't matter right it's above that
so what we need
is an implementation of the mock
and that will be
the final drama
and then the end will come
slow sunday the simple solution to
global warming
we
should restore sunday to a day for gaia
a day for the earth it's well said
modern
because the sabbath is a day for god yes
jesus is lord of the service
they went today for gaia they're welcome
to it but uh not for me thank you i want
no pardon that's it and unfortunately
that's not gonna be
without consequences no your decision on
that
so the churches together they want to
climate sunday first they want an annual
one but then they'll want a weekly one
eu bishops call for nations to protect a
work free sunday
so now let's get the unions on board and
work together with them participate and
protect sunday says the alliance for the
free sunday
jubilee for the earth looking for the
laudato seaweed that's the independent
catholic news martin
has the table been laid definitely if
i think you must if you cannot see
what's going on with these signs
take off your glasses wipe them clean
get some eye solve and look again look
again luke 21 28 and when these things
begin to come to pass
then
look up where were they going to look
they were going to look down right
around they were going to look down they
were going to look at gaia
and lift up your heads
for your redemption draweth night i am
so glad that all these signs are in
place
the environmental signs the spiritual
signs the messianic signs
the political signs
the buying and selling the economic
signs
and then the mark of the beast science
and this propaganda machine
is running crazy
it is
running at full ball it was only one
brief period in history
when it was running at that capacity but
that was local it was in one nature one
nation
that was in europe
but now we've surpassed it we've made it
universal may god give us wisdom
not to be deceived shall we pray please
heavenly father
the signs have fulfilled all around us
we're waiting for the final events
some more propaganda
some more indoctrination
some more lies
and then the end will come
give us wisdom and help us to be
faithful stewards of the word in jesus
name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again